so i have to ask do you watch any
youtubers
i have made a youtube watching debut so
um i'm just a newbie right now so i'm
starting to search for good channels
and i actually um i'm planning to start
my own channel as well all right oh okay
i'm sort of studying right now i'm
watching you guys and um well
i can't sing cosplay badly
what are you doing youtube channel i'm
just missing like half of the things i
plan to do are going to be music based
but half of the things are going to be
like just
for fun just for you know having fun
with my watchers
and me being me yeah so yeah any advice
oh that's a that's a loaded question
right there
click bait right
just make it something crazy yeah i said
every song
ever yeah titles and thumbnails are like
your bread and butter yeah
okay actually i'll tell you what you
could do anime opening singer reacts to
anime openings
tell me that's not gonna do well
professional anime
openings yeah that would actually do
really well
when you like break down being like okay
this is why this is a good anime
yeah that's why there's a bad anime
opening and like you can because you
have the authority to say that right as
someone who's made
as someone who's made multiple animes
what are some of your favorite anime
openings
if you'd if you can say that i really do
enjoy like you know
like i said full metal alchemist i
obviously like all their songs
and just i'm a i'm a rock artist so
i like rock based songs a lot and
yeah so do you just listen to the music
or do
you pay attention to like the actual
visuals and animation with it as well or
you just like okay this is a good song i
like the song
i think first i'll listen to the song
and then i'll watch the the visuals but
then i
end up just listening to the song itself
so yeah
that's me as well i feel that's the case
it's like
yeah if you just like especially as well
like if you like a song you
at least for me i'm like oh never heard
of this artist before i'm gonna
you know delve into everything else that
they have and then nine times out of ten
you realize
yeah there's probably a reason why
they're known for this song but i think
you know i do think
youtube is about being real and so i i
want to do
what i plan to do is to show like behind
the scenes stuff of a lot of the music
industry like what i can't
well there's there is a limit to what i
can show but i will try to
show you know some of the down and dirty
stuff you know that people
don't know about like in the recording
studio or like
behind the stage in my concert yeah yeah
and all these things and so i think i'm
i really want to just show people what
the music
industry is about yeah because what made
you want to start youtube because this
is
very different from the image we talked
about earlier of just like you know the
mysterious nano that's not exactly
the opposite of what i've been doing
yeah yeah yeah so is
was it is it just you just trying to
find something new trying to do
something different
that too but also it's just that i feel
that it's it's
it's more fitting in the generation to
not be perfect like right up until now
everything about
music was being you know perfect but in
this generation it's solely
about showing what's not perfect yeah
and people are more interested in the
imperfections of you know the
entertainment industry
so hopefully i can i've you know been
singing for eight years and i have seen
you know behind the scenes stuff so to
share that with the world
yeah that'd be super interesting yeah
because i feel that's like a very unique
position to be in as well like we can't
just rock up to like
a concert of yours and be like hey we're
backstage right now this is what it
looks like
without going through leaps and hurdles
of you know approval and stuff like that
and i do feel that that's a big reason
why youtube has grown
so large in recent years is because
people feel a connection with
youtubers because they see the
imperfections they see that they're not
this
perfect idol or perfect artist that you
know we
a lot of us came up from the same
background and i know you did as well
but it's it might be hard for someone to
like relate to that when they don't know
all the intimate details of your
background and
where you came up from so yeah that was
very interesting hearing your story
today
i mean sometimes it is scary to think
that you know showing people like you
know the
sort of like the mistakes and stuff of
the
recording studio and stuff but yeah at
the same time i think that there are not
a
lot of artists who are willing to show
that side yeah so um you know i'm going
to throw him
up throw away my pride and uh try to be
real with people you know show that you
know
recording does take a lot of effort
there's a lot of you know
um mistakes and redos
and you know it's just effort effort
effort after effort and then
the cd is created so it's not just you
know using it you record it you
put it together i'd be surprised there's
many people out there who actually think
that that it's just like
snails i mean there might be some
just amazing people who nail it and you
know just
but it's just you know it's real life so
um i'd love to be able to share that
started that sort of effort with people
you know
how much effort does go into making one
song and
one concert and so you know hopefully
people will find that interesting
and i might you know do a few weird
parodies
oh yeah yeah yeah i know i'll be very
interested i might uh
sing my own anime songs with the cosplay
that'll be they'll be dope as well
hopefully your channel will be
ready by the time this episode if it is
in the description
so he's like when were you planning to
debut your channel
um march 14th i think or march somewhere
around there
so hopefully uh it'll be ready before
that and then
yeah people can sort of maybe click on
it so if her channel is
up and ready it's gonna that you can
click on the link in the description to
subscribe to nano and uh oh i guess that
will be a week after this episode
airs so keep an eye out on that for that
as well you're really at home right now
so maybe i can just
uh just park here yeah yeah he could be
the fourth
fourth of july he could be one of the
boys
i think i need a trash taste opening
so maybe after this time i'm gonna like
just happen to appear every time you
know
like fourth fourth yeah definitely well
we'd love to have you back on sometime i
would love to be
back i think you know if you're gonna be
a youtuber you should do our outro for
us that's a very crucial part really
like an outro song no no no no outro for
the youtube video you know you have to
say like like comment subscribe
oh yeah you gotta yeah you gotta get
used to that all right
youtuber youtuber coaching session right
now okay so
all you have to do is look at the camera
and go hope you guys enjoyed the video
be sure to like comment and smash the
like button you have to stay smashed
you can't you can't just say you like
hit the like button it has to be like
smash the like
button holding the smash the like button
can i practice here yeah go go go go
ahead
everyone watching youtube thank you that
was nano you have to
smash the like button